>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Robert Newlen: Good
evening, everyone.
My name is Robert Newlen.
I'm Deputy Librarian of Congress.
And on behalf of the Librarian
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden,
it's my pleasure to welcome
you to the Library of Congress.
I'm so glad to see so many of you
here tonight for the presentation
of the 2016 Rebekah Johnson
Bobbitt National Prize for Poetry.
Before we begin, I'd like to note
that we are recording this event
for the Library's archive, and
for all to see on our website,
and would ask that you please
silence your cell phones
and any other electronics
you may have with you.
The Bobbitt Prize is
awarded every other year
to recognize the most
distinguished book of poetry written
by an American poet
over the last two years,
or the Lifetime Achievement
of an American poet.
With so many great
poets working today,
that's really no easy distinction.
We are indebted to the jurors who
read through over 120 submissions
from publishers large and
small, for this year's Prize.
Betty Sue Flowers, former
director of the LBJ Library Museum,
an emeritus professor of English at
the University of Texas at Austin,
has anchored the panel
for many years
as the Bobbitt family
representative.
Boston poet laureate,
Danielle George,
was selected by our own poet
laureate, Juan Felipe Herrera,
and the Librarian of Congress
selected national book award winning
poet, Mary Szybist.
To all future jurors, we thank
them for their hard work.
I would also like to
acknowledge the publishers
of this year's co-winners,
Graywolf Press,
and New Directions Publishing,
two of the nation's
powerhouse independents.
And finally, thank you to Dr. Philip
C. Bobbitt for his generous gift
that makes this Prize possible.
Professor Bobbitt is one
of the nation's leading
constitutional theorists,
the Herbert Wechsler professor,
a federal jurist prudence,
and director for the
Center for National Security
at Columbia Law School, a
distinguished senior lecturer
at the University of Texas, and
most importantly for us tonight,
his parents shared
a strong connection
to this wonderful institution.
To tell us more about
that, please join me
in welcoming Philip to the stage.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Philip Bobbitt: It's been my
great pleasure these last almost
three decades to say something at
these gatherings about my family,
and especially about my mother, in
whose honor this Prize is presented,
Becky Johnson of Johnson City, and
she was when she met my father here
at the Library of Congress,
in the 1930s.
My parent's story is
a Washington story.
Here they fell in love
during the Depression;
here they reluctantly
left when the War began.
My mother didn't really
want to leave Washington.
One of her suitors had bribed the
orchestra leader at the showroom
to play "The Yellow Rose of Texas"
whenever she came to the ballroom.
She wasn't going to get
anything like that in Austin.
She had, in fact, escaped Texas.
And I don't think she really
wanted to marry a man from Texas.
But they eloped to Mexico, they
lived together mainly in Texas
for 38 years until
my mother's death.
When she died, I found a cache
of some unusual index cards
in a pigeonhole in the
small green writing desk
where she did her correspondence
every day.
Each card had a hole drilled
in the center of the top line,
and on each was typed poetry or in
some cases a rather lofty saying.
I took them from my father, and I
said, "What are all these cards?"
I mean, there were dozens of them.
He said, "You remember that I
met your mother at the Library
of Congress when we were both
working our way through school."
My father had won a scholarship to
come to East to college from Texas.
My mother was studying library
science, as it was called then.
My father said to me, "You know
that your mother was engaged
to another man when we first met."
I said, "Yes; I sort
of remembered -- "
[ Non-Topic Comments ]
I said, "Yes; I do
sort of remember that,
a Princeton graduate," I thought.
"Well, I had to dislodge
this fellow,
but the only time I ever
saw your mother was at work.
And we had a very strict supervisor.
We worked in cataloguing.
And those cards are from
the card catalogues."
I mean, that explained the holes.
They really in fact belonged
in the bottom of the card.
"And we would exchange
notes as if we were typing
in reference information."
[Laughter] I've always
had a certain affection
for the Dewey Decimal System,
since I heard that story.
Anyway, my father and I sat and we
talked, and out of that conversation
that afternoon, came the idea of the
Poetry Prize here at the Library;
a Prize, which is now
in its 27th year.
Twenty-seven years ago, my
father and I came to the Library
of Congress, with a
librarian, and the poet laureate
to honor James Merrill,
the first recipient
of the Rebekah Johnson
Bobbitt Prize.
If the function of poetry
is not to inform, but evoke,
as the classicists tell us,
perhaps you will recognize something
in the following short poem by
James Merrill, something other
than the [inaudible],
which you'll all recognize,
something of the season
that has just passed,
and perhaps lingers
still in this town.
It's called "Snow Jobs."
"X had the funds, the
friends, the plan.
Wise Frank Grin [phonetic]
was our common fate,
or really just a flash in pan.
Z from the tender age of eight,
had thirsted to officiate.
We hardly felt him disappear.
The crooked and the X had the
funds, the friends, the plan.
The crooked and the
somewhat straight.
Now, where's the slush
of yesteryear?
[Laughter] Where's Teapot Dome?
Where's the Iran Contra Affair?
Where's Watergate?
Liddy, Magruder, Ehrlichman, their
shoes squeaked down the Halls
of State, whole networks
groaned beneath their weight.
Until spinster Clotho darted near
to shroud in white a running mate.
Ah, where's the slush of yesteryear?
Like blizzards on a screen
the scandals thickened
at a fearful rate, followed
by laughter from a can,
and hot air from the candidate.
With so much open to
debate, language that went
in one ear came out, "Oh,
well, hush, be delicate."
Where is the slush of yesteryear?
Omniscient host, throughout your
great late shows the crystal wits
cohere, the flaky banks accumulate.
But where's the slush
of yesteryear?"
Well, that's from Jimmy Merrill.
Depending on how you count,
this is either the 14th
or the 16th Prize to be awarded.
That's because tonight,
as only once before,
the Library is also
awarding a Bobbitt Prize
for Lifetime Achievement in Poetry.
So I thought I might just close
by saying something about how
that particular P Prize came about.
The members of my family have
never been, and should not be,
involved in the selection of
the winners for this Prize.
We're not poets, we're
critics, or editors of poetry.
And besides, the juries that have
selected past winners have done
pretty damned well.
Merrill, Glick, Strands, Ammons,
Colt, Bedard, Ferry, Fulton,
Fairchild, Merwin, Wright, Hicok,
Perillo, Smith, Stern, what a list.
Robert Pinsky, our three-time
poet laureate said, and I quote,
"No other literary prize has set
such a high standard," end quote.
And this year's winner,
Claudia Rankine,
rightly joins this
remarkable collegiate.
Of her work, "Citizen," one will not
hear what a witty critic once said
of another long poem, "This book
will be read when every other volume
of poetry published this
year has long been forgotten,
but not until then."
[Laughter] For in fact "Citizen"
has been a smash success.
Nevertheless, there were
poets whose work we loved
and hoped would be recognized with
the Prize given in my mother's name.
Howard Nemerov is one.
But he died shortly after
the Prize was inaugurated.
[Inaudible] was another.
And he died, also without
ever having one.
I discussed the matter with some
of the persons here at the Library
who were familiar with
the selection process.
[Inaudible] may be one of them.
Well, they told me,
"The person chosen
for the Bobbitt Prize has produced
the most distinguished work
in the last two years.
Those poets whose work you love,
Philip, may not have done that.
Some of them may not
even be writing now."
So for reason it was
decided to create a Prize
for Lifetime Achievement.
Naturally, I assume as
we go to an older person,
by which I mean older than I am.
[Laughter] I was the only child
of somewhat older parents,
the youngest grandchild
in my family.
Being a bright boy, much
brighter than I am now,
I was always the youngest in my
class, in my schools, in my college.
One consequence of this was
that I've unconsciously assumed
that at any gathering, I
will be the youngest person.
[Laughter] It's not that I thought
of myself as particularly young,
I just thought of everyone
else around my age as older.
So imagine my shock to
realize that the winner
of the Lifetime Achievement Award
is a fellow I went to college with.
But you don't win the
[inaudible] 27, do you?
Nathaniel Mackey would have been 27
at the same time I finished clerking
and moved back to Austin to live
with my parents, in a large house
and take up a professorship
at the University at Austin.
We were a very close family.
But none of us knew how little
time we three would have together.
Or were there four; for I haven't
mentioned my beloved Mary Lewis.
One ought to be circumspect
in discussing the suffering
and oppression of others.
Never looks the same
from the outside,
whether it's an ear
ache, or a racist remark.
American slaves were not settlers,
and they were not immigrants.
They were brought to this
continent in chains, and maintained
in their condition as chattels.
But that does not change
the fact so often ignored
that the US would not have thrived,
would not even have successfully
managed its independence
without the African Americans
who came here against their will.
I don't know all that we owe
those original generations
of African Americans and
therefore owe their descendants,
or even the best way
for us to discharge
that obligation if I did know.
But I know this, that African
Americans have always had a right
to be here, that they have
in Sam Houston's words,
"Watered the soil with their blood."
And it is a source
of some dismay to me
that many don't feel fully
invested in this country,
don't feel that it is
properly and rightfully theirs,
not just as a matter of equality,
but as a matter of birthright.
Mary Lewis came to work
for my family a few
months before I was born.
I was a large, lazy baby, and my
mother was tall but not strong.
So she was there every
day and many nights.
She traveled with us and
toted me around the world.
In the end, she stayed
with us for over 40 years.
I talked to her daughter yesterday.
And although we were very close,
it wasn't because of
me that she stayed.
It was because of the bonds
she had forged with my mother.
Now, my mother was a woman
of her time and place.
She was no egalitarian.
And I think she disapproved of most
people's behavior, white or black.
[Laughter] But she was
close to Mary Lewis
in a way that's hard to describe.
It has something to do with
there being women in a world
of headstrong men, and something
also with their shared love
of patellio [phonetic] and style.
We know from antiquity of the birth
of a society comes
in crime and pain.
Think of "The Rape of the
Sabine Women," for example.
But whatever our desperate origins,
we have created an enduring society
when so many others have failed.
We should take pride in our
endurance; and not only endurance,
but that we have prevailed, all
of us, one nation out of many,
under God, still seeking
liberty and justice for all.
Our little daughter is
about 27 months old.
She is the eighth Rebekah
in our family,
named for the woman
this Prize commemorates.
What sort of past will she reflect
on when she and her brother stand
where I'm standing to present
this Prize 27 years from now?
Like a physicist, I'm an optimist,
by which mean I think
the future is uncertain.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Newlen: Thank you, Philip,
for supporting the Library's
tradition of honoring poetry
with this prize in
your mother's name.
In 2008 the Bobbitt Prize was split
between Bob Hicok for his book,
"The Clumsy Living," and future
poet laureate Charles Wright
for his lifetime achievement.
This was the first time the
Prize honored both categories,
and now nearly a decade later,
a pair of poets merit
this recognition again.
I am pleased tonight to award
the 2016 Rebekah Johnson Bobbitt
National Prize for Poetry to Claudia
Rankine for her book, "Citizen,"
and to Nathaniel Mackey
for Lifetime Achievement.
[ Applause ]
In complementary ways, both of
our winners argue for poetry
as an essential way to invent
myths, and interrogate institutions,
champion the music of direct speech,
and the complex lyricism of meaning,
and give shape to our imagination.
Rankine's book, "Citizen," winner
of the National Book Critic
Circle Award, the Forward Prize,
and the Jackson Poetry Prize,
achieved a rare feat for poetry.
It reached and moved a mass audience
in this country, and
around the world.
The Washington Post called
"Citizen," "Part protest lyric,
part art book, and a
dazzling expression
of the painful double consciousness
of black life in America."
Book Forum added that, "'Citizen'
is an anatomy of American racism
in the new millennium, a
slender musical book that arrives
with the force of a thunderclap."
And finally, Robert Newlen says,
"'Citizen' is an astounding
collision of verse and visuals."
The National Endowment of the
Arts recognized the enduring power
of "Citizen" when they added it
to their nationwide Big
Read initiative last year.
The year before, Yale University
award the Bollingen Prize in Poetry,
the Library's first poetry
prize, as well as the model
for the Bobbitt Prize,
to Nathaniel Mackey.
The Bollingen judges declared
Nathaniel Mackey's decades long
serial work, "'Songs
of Andoumboulou,
" and 'Mu' constitutes one
of the most poetic
achievements of our time.
'Outer Pradesh,' jazz-inflected,
outward writing, passionately smart,
open and wise, beautifully
continues this ongoing project."
Mackey's many other honors include
the Poetry Foundation's honor
for Lifetime Achievement,
the Ruth Lilly Prize.
In his citation for the Prize,
"Poetry Magazine" editor,
Don Share noted that, "Mackey's
poetry ambitiously continues an
American bardic [phonetic] line
that unfolds from "Leaves of Grass,
to Pound's 'Cantos,' to HD's,
'Trilogy' winds through the whole
of Robert Duncan's work, and
extends beyond all of these."
Mackey's own rare combinations
create an astonishing
and resounding effect.
His words go where music goes, a
brilliant and major accomplishment."
We could not be more
grateful to celebrate two
of America's trailblazing
poets tonight.
Please join me in welcoming Claudia
Rankine, and Nathaniel Mackey.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Claudia Rankine: Good evening.
>> Good evening.
>> Claudia Rankine: Whenever
I come to Washington,
I feel like I come to America.
[Laughter] It's very, very,
very monumental to be here.
[Laughter] I would love to thank
the Bobbitt Family for this Prize,
and everyone at the
Library of Congress.
And also it -- I cannot
communicate to you how honored I am
to share this evening
with Nate Mackey,
whose work has been
behind my own work.
So I'm much younger than he is.
I just want you to -- [laughter]
no, he has been so important to me
over the years, so it's a
double honor; a double honor.
I was thinking about
what Mr. Bobbitt said
about the future being uncertain.
And that is probably the most
optimistic thing I have heard
in a long time.
[ Background Sounds ]
I'm going to read three
poems from "Citizen."
[ Background Sounds ]
The first poem is in memory
of James Craig Anderson.
He was killed by Deryl
Dedmon in 2011.
And I've been thinking a lot about
young white men who are caught
by white supremacy inside
a kind of disassociation
from their own humanity, and
from humanity in general,
and from America as their
country, and this sense
that they would rather
become murderers
than share this country
with people of color.
It seems to me a kind of
wrong-headed equation around a sense
of feeling lost and
disaffected inside our landscape.
I read -- I recently read the
journals of Dylann Roof, and he --
they're fascinating, if you have
a Sunday afternoon to read them.
And he said that killing
those nine people
in Charleston was something
he had to do.
And he knew that he
would have to go to jail.
But he also felt that he would
be pardoned, which is the one --
of everything I read
it's the one thing
that I haven't been able to forget.
Because it is a sense of a certain
world that has come into power;
and that sense that that
world will save him.
"'In the next frame, the
pickup truck is in motion.
Its motion activates its darkness.
The pickup truck is a
condition of darkness in motion.
It makes a dark subject.'
'You mean a black subject.'
'No, a black object.
Then the pickup is beating the
black object to the ground.
And the tire marks, the
crushed organs, then the audio.
'I ran that nigger over' is itself
a record-breaking hot June day
in the 21st century.
'The pickup returns us to
live cruelty, like sunrise,
red streaks falling
from dawn to asphalt.
Then again, this pickup is not
about beauty, it's a pure product.'
The announcer patronizes
the pickup truck.
'No hoodlums, just teens.
No gang, just a teen with straggly
blond hair, a slight blond man.'
The pickup is human in
this predictable way.
Do you recognize yourself, Dedmon?
In the circulating photo
you are looking down.
Were you dreaming of this day
all the days of your youth?
In the daydream, did the
pickup take you home?
Was it a pickup fueling the road
to, 'I ran that nigger over?'
Baldwin says, 'Skin color
cannot be more important
than the human being.'
And was the pickup constructing
an exploding whiteness out of you?
You are so sorry.
You are angry, an explosive
anger, an effective one.
'I ran that nigger over.'
James Craig Anderson is dead.
The pickup truck is
a figure of speech.
It is, as the crown,
standing in for the kingdom.
'Who told you it was a crown?
Did we tell you the
pickup was as good as home?
You are so young, Dedmon.
You were so young.
James Craig Anderson is dead.
What ails you, Dedmon?
What up?' 'What's up is James
Craig Anderson is dead.'
'So sorry, so angry,
an imploding anger.
It must let you go.
It let you go.'"
[ Background Sounds ]
[ Non-Topic Conversation ]
I --
[ Background Sounds ]
I wrote this poem about a month
before Trayvon Martin was killed.
And then someone said to me, "You
wrote this for Trayvon Martin."
And so -- I mean, it came out sort
of after he died and people said
to me, "Oh, you wrote this
in memory of Trayvon Martin."
So I decided that I wrote it
in memory of Trayvon Martin.
[Laughter] "My brothers
are notorious.
They have not been to prison,
they have been imprisoned.
The prison is not a place
you enter; it is no place.
My brothers are notorious.
They do regular things like wait.
On my birthday they say my name.
They will never forget
that we are named.
What is that memory?
The days of our childhood
together were steep steps
into a collapsing mind.
It looked like we rescued
ourselves, or rescued.
Then there are these days
each day of our adult lives.
They will never forget our
way through these brothers,
each brother my brother,
dear brother,
my dearest brothers, dear heart.
Your hearts are broken.
This not a secret,
though there are secrets.
And as yet I do not understand
how my own sorrow has turned
into my brother's hearts.
The hearts of my brothers
are broken.
If I knew another way to be,
I would call up a brother.
I would hear myself
saying, 'My brother,
dear brother, my dearest brothers.
Dear heart.'
On the tip of a tongue one node
following another is another path,
another dawn, where the pink sky is
a bloodshot of struck [phonetic],
of sleepless, of sorry,
of senseless.
Shush. Those years of and
before me and my brothers,
the years of passage, plantation,
migration of Jim Crow segregation,
of poverty, inner cities profiling,
of one and three, two jobs.
Boy, hey boy, each
a felony accumulate
into the hours inside our lives,
where we are all caught hanging.
The rope inside us, the tree
inside us, its roots are limbs,
a throat sliced through; and when we
open our mouth to speak, blossoms.
Oh, blossoms.
No place coming out.
Brother, dear brother,
that kind of blue.
The sky is the silence of brothers
all the days leading up to my call.
If I called, I'd say goodbye.
Before I broke the goodbye,
I'd say goodbye before anyone
can hang up; don't hang up.
My brother hands up
though he's there.
I keep talking.
The talk keeps him there.
The sky is blue, kind of blue.
Today is hot.
Is it cold?
Are you cold?
It does get cool as it cools.
Are you cool?
My brother is completed by sky.
The sky is a silence.
Eventually he says, 'It is raining.
It is raining down.
It was raining.
It stopped raining.
It is raining down.'
He won't hang up.
He's there.
He's there but he's hung
up, though he's there.
'Goodbye,' I say.
I break the goodbye.
I say goodbye before
anyone can hang up.
Don't hang up.
Wait with me.
Wait with me, though the waiting
might be the call of goodbyes."
[ Background Sounds ]
And the final piece; so that we
can get ourselves some Nate Mackey.
[Laughter] "Some years there
exists a wanting to escape you,
floating above your certain ache.
Still the ache coexists.
Call that the imminent you.
You are you even before you grow
into understanding you are not
anyone, worthless, not worth you.
Even as your own weight
insists, you are here,
fighting off the weight
of nonexistence.
And still this life parts your lids,
you see you seeing your
extending hand as a falling wave.
I, they, he, she, we, you turn
only to discover the encounter
to be alien to this place.
Wait, the patience is in the living.
Time opens out to you.
The opening, between you and you,
occupied, zoned for an encounter.
Given the histories of you and
you, and always, who is this you?
The start of you, each
day, a presence already.
Hey you, slipping down,
burying the you buried within.
You are everywhere and you
are nowhere in the day.
The outside comes in.
Then you, hey you,
overheard in the moonlight,
overcome in the moonlight.
Soon you are sitting
around, publicly listening.
When you hear this, what
happens to you doesn't belong
to you, only half concerns you.
He is speaking of the legionnaires
in Claire Denis's film 'Beau
Travail,' and you are pulled back
into the body of you
receiving the nothing gaze.
The world out there insisting
on this only half concerns you.
What happens to you doesn't belong
to you, only half concerns you.
It's not yours.
Not yours only.
And still a world begins
its furious erasure.
Who do you think you
are, saying I to me?
You're nothing.
You're nobody.
You. A body in the
world drowns in it.
Hey you. All our fevered
history won't instill insight,
won't turn a body conscious, won't
make that look in the eyes say yes,
though there is nothing to solve
even as each moment is an answer.
Don't say I if it means so little,
holds the little forming no one.
You're not sick, you're hurt.
You ache for the rest of life.
How to care for the injured
body, the kind of body
that can't hold the
content it is living?
And where is the safest place
when that place must be
someplace other than in the body?
Even now your voice entangles this
mouth whose words are here as pulse,
strumming shut out,
shut in, shut up.
You cannot say.
A body translates its you.
You there, hey you, even as it
loses the location of its mouth.
When you lay your body in
the body entered as if skin
and bone were public places,
when you lay your body
in the body entered as if
you're the ground you walk on,
you know no memory should live
in these memories becoming
the body of you.
You slow all existence down with
your call, detectable only as sky.
The night's yawn absorbs you as
you lie down at the wrong angle
to the sun ready already
to let go of your hand.
Wait with me, though
the waiting, wait up,
might take until nothing
whatsoever was done.
To be left, not alone, the only wish
to call you out, to call out you.
Who shouted you?
You shouted you, you the murmur
in the air, you sometimes sounding
like you, you sometimes saying you,
go nowhere, be no one but you first.
Nobody notices, only you've known.
You're not sick, not
crazy, not angry, not sad.
It's just this, you're hurt.
Everything shaded,
everything darkened,
everything shadowed is the
stripped, is the struck,
is the trace, is the aftertaste.
I, they, he, she, we, you
were too concluded yesterday
to know whatever was
done could also be done,
was also done, was never done.
The worst injury is feeling you
don't belong so much to you."
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Nathaniel Mackey:
Thank you, Claudia,
for your very deep,
and stirring reading.
And thanks to the Library
of Congress,
and the Bobbitt Family
for bringing us here.
Claudia and I read together 15 years
ago at the University of Chicago,
at Fayette Wilberson [phonetic].
So it's nice to be reunited.
[ Background Sounds ]
The phrase, "lifetime achievement"
has a rather ominous ring.
[Laughter] And I'm going
to read recent work
that hasn't been published
in book form yet.
I'm not done yet.
[Laughter] And --
[ Applause ]
I just wanted to let you know.
[Laughter] The poem I'll begin with,
since we're here in Washington, DC,
it's the last poem in a volume that
will be called "Tashbet" [phonetic].
And it's -- I only work -- I only
write, you know, a couple of poems.
One is called "Song
of the Andoumboulou,"
and the other is called "Mu."
And they go on.
The book that I most recently
published, "Mufasa," ends with "Song
of the Andoumboulou 110."
And "Tashbet" ends with this one,
"Song of the Andoumboulou 160."
And those of you acquainted with
the work know that it's come
to be a kind of song of migration,
the migration of a
traveling group known as "we."
In a country called "Nub."
It bears some resemblance
to this country, a world --
a planet called "Nub" bears
some resemblance to this planet.
And this one was recently published
in the nation back in the fall.
Even though it was written a few
years ago, it was actually written
around the time of
the midterm elections.
"Nub's pendular politics
took our wind away.
Suf [phonetic] was all
sigh, exasperation.
We'd sat on a beach, biting hard
apples during an early go-around.
Nothing we knew amounted to much.
Only this or that oscillatory
witness, a topography of grief,
regret rolled out under our feet.
I thought of [inaudible],
low-hanging hips,
and the honey-based perfume her
night garments had given off.
[Inaudible] of win, the book Sophia
wrote us into again and again.
The word we thought meant 'injury,'
meant 'winding,' we found out.
I wanted whatever might last
to last, knowing nothing would.
The words '[inaudible]' eternity
as close as we ever come.
The words 'conjoined rehearsal,'
each the others second recess.
I wanted not to be yelling
what was wrong, but I was.
'Mama too tight' [phonetic]
might have been
on the box, but I wasn't sure.
So it was, or so it seemed, or
seeming so, it made me reckon,
warble to one side,
moved clamor to another,
a worrying of all it was we knew.
One would know the
quality of what I fled
by my awakeness [phonetic],
my doctrine held.
Doctrinal as I had let
myself be, not very.
Awakeness turned all doctrine away.
So with my rescinding
of souls, weak resolve,
Nubs rescinded steps
inoculant [phonetic],
a mirror might I have
gotten it to look.
So it was I wasn't the only
one yelled, 'What was wrong?'
Nubs forward steps in consequence.
Nubs turned back on cue.
Netsonet [phonetic] pliant hips,
remote planted [phonetic] honey
wafted my head lifted there.
I was older now, [inaudible]
the elders, avatar,
be he mine as well as me his.
Nub's raw cry rubbed us bloodless.
Gauge and more gauge I
reached into a nested set;
some recollection lay inside.
I requested a song, my
reluctance to sing built out from,
song number 40 times four; song
number four to the second times ten;
four to the third times five divided
by two; song I'd be tied in knots
and now singles number; song
Nub's temporizing led me to.
Netsonet, fresh from
her bath, I remembered,
balm against Nub's regression,
regressive itself no matter.
Soft cloths of fumes
with [inaudible] honey,
skin so diffused as well.
All of this light years away, so
remote it appeared, an unreal world,
or another world, or another life,
mine would insisted itself to be.
I was older now, [inaudible] the
elders, avatar, he's mine as well.
Nub's pendular politics
endless waft with respite,
honey heart's would be regime.
So said song number four
times 80, divided by two,
the song a reluctance
to sing set forth.
Song so undone by Nub's pendular
politics, Nub's back and forth,
so much more back than forth.
Song I made myself breathe
in, not wanting to sing.
Suf, one with suffusion,
Suf, nothing but soul, soul,
nothing at all, if not respite.
[Inaudible], we were times
catch, reminiscent kiss,
reminiscent caress,
Netsonet's must recombinant,
song number four times 40,
song 320 divided by two.
All was number, abstract figure,
[inaudible] such as we with no skin
to be had remitted more than we
have seen, or admitted we saw.
Song number four times
four, times ten;
song number ten times two times
eight; song sung high on the moon
without wind, [inaudible],
some distention it seemed.
Was it us getting old, or
the world, everyone wondered.
Abstract figure, and I see falsetto.
Song number 80 times 2.
A true institute of
sentiment it seemed,
reminiscent regard,
reminiscent regret.
To the feel, to the feeling, memory
escalated, release come to haunt,
release come to heal,
release newly other to itself.
Snub, nubs, buns, [inaudible];
pure permutation.
Abstract figure, abstract
filigree, abstract blaze [phonetic].
Snub, nubs, buns, and [inaudible]
spat, last love songs, seven,
abstract boast, abstract
bluster would be dispatched.
We were spinning our
wheels, beginners again.
Splinters pricked us on the
ass on the learners bench,
each of us a fool come off
a hill, as off a throne.
Snub, nubs, buns, a
lesson we learned by rote.
Snub, nubs, buns, part
past, part secret pledge,
said as if never to be heard again.
Funny time no sooner
rose that faded.
Lucky for us who were
otherwise unlucky.
Nubs knew cathartics, a rumble in
our stomachs, outside in, you know.
We were marking time,
led by Nub's temporizing.
Legs netted, fish with
feet it seemed.
We were marked by time, run
to and fro, Netsonet's crew.
Reaches will be done,
our sweet-tooth wish.
What thus we'd have come
to, we could only guess.
Going on the need to
go on, Nub-like.
I wanted the past back.
Netsonet visited me in a dream.
I told her I think about her often.
She said to me not to tell her that.
Sweet figment of one
day when we were young,
admit I was Anunsio
[phonetic] the elder again.
Autumn's tally lassoed my legs,
hooves at whose ends
would've been fish feet.
Song number fourscore twice.
What to go on, but the
need to go on kept at us.
Buzz inside and out
we were put on by.
It was a question we swung
at, wanted to knock down,
a question we waved
away as we could.
Crossroads called us out, loomed
at us, leg bug lassoed our legs.
Netted where we fish, roped where
we cattle, song 640 divided by four.
Pure figure, pure form,
pure permutation.
We knew Nub's minions gun
us down with impunity.
Was it time or a particular
time we wanted out of?
Time itself tainted,
never not particular.
Time's particularity, the rope we
were caught by, net we were caught
up in, we needed to know.
Song number two times two, times
two times 20, roundabout numbering,
naming, named where none was before.
A late entry in the book of soul,
her dire sport [phonetic] soul mate,
the wise one, or the wounded one,
her dire sport soul mate he'd be.
The wise one or the wounded one
walked holding my hand beside
the ledge.
I bit my lip, feeling
trudge along so.
I held back tears, the wise one,
who was also the wounded one.
Wise to what end I wanted to know.
Which of us was the pilgrim,
I also wanted to know.
No way, something told
me, were we both.
On into the enveloping fable,
deeper it insisted we go.
The thing that was happening,
all of it, the bit of it,
the something somehow telling
it the tale we'd come to know.
Up late watching election
results back when,
lineaments like none, Sophia sensed.
Calling it names, Nubs, stub,
flub, scrub, no release, no matter.
Honey musk may be a
match, but no matter,
hell bound Edmar [phonetic] said.
I said, 'They're all ready.'
'The poverty of politics would be
with us always,' Aja
[phonetic] put in.
Bounty be found all the same.
Thought of Netsonet crowded
the room, the night balm
where none otherwise was.
Calm came over us, to divide
between legs what recompense we
who were not always meat and bone.
So it seemed and seeming
so, so it was.
Young wager come back to be real.
All I took to be [inaudible].
Nub never not with us,
never not prod, pebble,
pearl there would eventually be."
[ Background Sounds ]
Where are we on time?
Okay; this is the poem that follows
that poem, and the book that follows
that book, which is
called "Souls Notice."
And it's a book -- it's
a poem in the Mu series.
I've developed this habit of writing
about bands, or creating bands
in my writing, in my prose,
famously so, but it's also something
that started happening in my poems.
"Air bands," I guess
you would call them.
[Laughter] And one
of them that has come
to be is the over ghost orchestra.
And this poem is called "The
Over Ghost Orchestra's Next."
And this poem actually
led to a talk, lecture,
a paper that I wrote called
"Breath and Precarity."
It was written after the killing
of Eric Garner and his last words,
"I can't breath," which
has become a rallying cry.
And I was thinking about how much
breath gets expended in black music,
which is one of the things that has
buoyed us up over all these decades.
And the phrase, "No
matter we couldn't breathe,
we blew" started things to happen.
One of the great things about living
in North Carolina now is that I got
to visit High Point, which is
where John Coltrane grew up.
And I actually found the
address of his old --
of the house he grew up in, and
I went by there and visited,
and was happy to find out that
it was right around the corner
from the Toussaint
Louverture Mason Lodge.
[Laughter] That comes up in
the poem towards the end.
"Nubs knew facelift got old.
War droned on, money stayed on top.
The abandoned boy and girl
went by every name known.
Still, we bit the bullet and blew.
'I will be and I'll believe
when I blow,' we announced.
'I will be and abide by
sound, my slave day done.'
We were back on Saint Sufferhead's
[phonetic] porch, a promontory.
Some same tunes temporizing
remit, reminiscent romance,
the feral's black torso reached for
and found [inaudible] arrows again.
We were the feral's black
torso, lost and found again,
thick reeds stuck to
a dry lower lip,
chapped kiss calling itself song, or
siblings, some same tunes high cry.
We were the feral's black torso
cloat [phonetic], a call for cover,
shot body, sirening alarm, we lost
and found again, pantomimes
[inaudible].
So it was, so we said, or
so we played canting say-so.
Torn cloaks rule unrelenting.
Torn cloak routing the day.
Could we but be a band it
would all go away we thought,
or we played like we thought.
Could we but be a band
it would all be okay.
So it was we were in a band,
so it was not so the same.
What we cut we'd call a release;
release what we called out for.
It had been going on
for only a minute.
for as long as we knew.
Nub said to be having
a conversation,
no such one were we in.
Unable to breathe,
though we were, we blew,
the crook of Nub's arm on our necks.
We played with our hands
up, axis untouched, release,
it was Teji's [phonetic]
bet would be sweet.
Nub held my neck in the crook of its
arm, the unworded song we sang said.
Nub took me down, but
I was swinging.
I got up swinging.
Could we only band or bond,
we thought, but it wasn't so.
Together as we were, we
suffered original suffer heads.
Original suffer heads for all
eternity it seemed, wise ones,
and wounded ones it seemed.
The empathetic string
ensemble skipped out.
A gig in the Czech
Republic, they said.
So it was we were on our
own, erstwhile accompaniment,
in the ground we got up from,
hot lights spiraling behind.
Pulling thread from
string, string from rope,
we'd have been had they been
there, a fraught way to feel,
a fugue for the wretched
blows to the head as we blew.
Hands up, windpipes
crushed, we blew.
Over ghost [inaudible], behest.
A high falsetto wind put
parts in our hair again.
We heard bells, an avid
choir breaking glass they hit
such high notes.
Heads, all honey housed it seemed.
Choked, held, haloed, we wanted
to say, but came up short.
Hot light popping swept,
no matter the high wind,
no matter where we were,
wherever it was we were.
Hot light away we dwelt elsewhere.
It was never just there we were.
Wherever it was we were,
we were birds again,
each with our own song,
each with a tutor song.
'Teach me, tutor me,' we sang.
Not withstanding we
couldn't breathe, we blew.
A Masonic windpipe we resorted to
circular breathing with we blew.
'Luvature' we called it, church key,
millet beer wept what
words there were.
It was an underground pipeline
we got our breath back through.
'Teach me, tutor me,' the words
that were thirst a way of knowing,
not knowing, naustic
[phonetic], more stoic now.
Our first day in the
land of the dead it was.
Breathless though we were, we blew.
Took a stand we were
taking down, we justified.
Arrest what of Earth we
remembered, all else taken away.
So went the record what we read
into the record, new tears for Eric,
new tunes for another Eric,
commiserative our posture
must release.
'Live in the land of the
dead,' we might have called it.
Not withstanding we
couldn't breathe, we blew.
No matter we couldn't breathe,
we blew, we kept insisting.
Over ghost tremolo, over ghost
vibrato, over ghost cul de sac,
come to and come back from;
over ghost conversancy, no end.
In the heart of [inaudible],
west of Egypt,
no matter we couldn't
breathe, we blew.
No pitch, no tone, pulse only, a
tutor song, police batons taught us,
hexameters tapped out
with a stick; liner note.
The idea was we were
dead, already dead,
always the same whipped,
already dead.
The idea was we blew, not
yet knowing we were dead.
To blow was to hope
against hope we had air,
no matter we couldn't breathe,
breathe in, breathe out.
No matter we couldn't
breathe, keep breathing.
The idea was we were
a claim the dead made.
The idea we were a
strain put on the living.
The idea was time turned
back, put its back to us.
Back at some serial onslaught,
back at us, again and again.
[ Paper Sounds ]
We convened around the
corner from Coltrane's house,
the Toussaint Louverture
Masonic Lodge.
Acknowledgment hit,
we bowed our heads.
It was nothing if not love's
arcade, and we wanted that,
the idea we'd grounded
off with that.
'Live in outer space'
we might have called it.
'Why did they send us off the
planet so soon,' we wanted to know.
Demanded someone say, got no answer.
Lynch laws return; had it ever left?
Nightsticks and nooses,
no new facelift now.
Breath, even would be breath,
our eventual escort
hydraulic circles we blew.
Better born a dog [inaudible] we
squalled, calling up step even so.
Giant steps, no, not
even steps, step.
'Step' said everything,
all that we're about.
Hit, hoist, hover, hover,
highest iconic stare, step."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you both for
a terrific reading.
And now we have the final part
of our little reading
and ceremony here.
I'd like to welcome again the
Deputy Librarian of Congress,
Robert Newlen to come
up, and our two winners;
and Mr. Bobbitt, please come up too.
We'll fit everybody up on the stage.
[ Backgrounds Sounds ]
>> I got everybody?
Okay. The Library of
Congress is pleased
to award the 2016 Rebekah Johnson
Bobbitt National Prize in Poetry
to Claudia Rankine and
to Nathaniel Mackey.
Please give [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
All right; we have books
for sale at the back by both
of our wonderful prize-winning
poets.
Please buy them, and they will
sign them at the table over there.
And please fill out the surveys
that were on your chairs,
and you can leave them
on your chairs,
or at the tables in the back.
It's useful for us to know what
you think about our programming.
Next Wednesday our poet laureate,
Juan Felipe Herrera is
giving his final event.
Please come to that.
You can check it out
at www.loc.gov/poetry.
Until then, have a good night.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.